adopter une stratégie pour mieux
répartir les logements sociaux sur saint
quentin en yvelines à l'objectif de la
première conférence intercommunal
organisé ce mercredi 22 février attrape
par les douze communes du territoire
les représentants se sont réunis pour
débattre de ce thème qui concernent 33
8% des logements sur le secteur c'est
important parce qu'il s'agit de l'avenir
de notre territoire il comment on veut
équilibrer le peuplement de nos
logements
donc ça intéresse les douze communes de
cette agglomération et ça nous oblige à
travailler ensemble pour pour équilibrer
notre territoire en terme de logement
aujourd'hui les logements sociaux sont
principalement concentrés sur deux
communes trappe aiguille en cours qui
représente 43 % du parc social de saint
quentin en yvelines
la finalité en fait de cette conférence
est de mettre au point une stratégie de
peuplement en semble commune qui fasse
que toutes les personnes qui attribue
des logements ce qu'on appelle les
réservataires s'y conforment
pour je dirais ne pas continuer à
concentrer les difficultés au même
endroit voilà où dans la même cage
d'escalier de nouvelles conférences sur
ce thème seront organisées par saint
quentin en yvelines dans les prochains
mois pour définir une stratégie commune